What I'd like to do today is to talk to you about what it is that distinguishes
a European ideas about the shared history of the last century,
uh,
and uh,
the United States.
What makes Europe European,
uh,
and what makes its sense of history different from,
from ours.
And I think the primary difference,
um,
between Europe and the United States will be seen in about six days on the 11th
of November when honest,
the stay is commemorated all over Europe.
In fact,
it's now commemorated in eastern Europe as well as in western Europe since it
took the fall of the Soviet Union to remind people that 2 million Russian
soldiers died in the first world war.
And that the eastern front was the place where,
uh,
the German army won the war and where the Russian revolution came directly out
of it.
Uh,
so the first world war is what made Europe in the 20th century European,
uh,
and it created the war,
created a series of wounds that to a degree have never healed to a degree.
Uh,
and the primary reason for that is the bloodshed as the staggering casualties of
a degree and magnitude that no one had ever seen before.
When we talk about,
uh,
losses on the scale of the first world war,
we enter a surreal terrain.
I have great difficulty getting my mind around a figures of 1 million casualties
for the battle of [inaudible] 1916 or just about the same number for the battle
of the Somme.
Battle of Ed don between February,
1916 and November was the longest battle in history.
It was 10 months without a break.
Uh,
there was nothing like it in the Second World War.
It pushed soldiers,
human beings beyond the limits of human endurance.
And the primary,
uh,
way in which this wound has been remembered as is in terms of an array of
commemorative practices,
which describe what European identity is.
Uh,
not only was but his,
and I want to suggest that there are many reasons why the remembrance of the
first world war has carried on throughout the 20th century in a defining way.
Um,
the first is,
is technology.
It's an accident that the first world war happened at the very moment that the
film industry became the centerpiece of mass entertainment and has,
this was the very first film make war,
and it was film make in a fictional way.
That is to say the technology of the day provided motion picture cameras for all
major armies.
And indeed they were used in all kinds of ways.
The problem was they never filmed battle.
We're almost never filmed battle.
They one or two exceptions.
But the important point is that generals and their staffs didn't want cameras on
the battlefield,
partly because it might produce evidence that would be useful to the other side.
And the other part of it is that the film might get back home and the family's
got to see it.
Then what would happen?
There's a famous story of the fictional film representation of war,
which is one reason why I think it is so iconic as a descriptive
element in European consciousness about the past,
uh,
in 1916 in the middle of the battle of the Somme,
which was a six months quagmire,
started by the British army on the 1st of July,
1916 and ended up roughly November,
1916 two for no gain whatsoever,
and a million casualties in the middle of it,
a part of the British,
uh,
propaganda,
um,
office.
It wasn't a ministry until 1918 was all done more or less informally until then,
uh,
decided to make a film to buck up public morale.
And so what they did was they filmed the battle of the Somme while it was being
fought,
but they didn't fill in the fighting.
They filmed mock episodes were soldiers in training,
uh,
would go over the top in,
um,
a totally fictional representation of war.
The problem was that the people who saw this didn't know that it was found a.
And so when the film was shown in,
not in the middle of 1916 and August,
September,
1916 in the battle started on the 1st of July,
it was Shawn all over Britain,
20 million people saw it.
That is half of the population of the country.
There has never been a film that was seen by half of the population of any
country in the world before that date or since it broke all box office records.
And what it showed in silence was the preparation for the battle,
the huge artillery barrage,
and then men going over the top.
And because it was phony,
there were men who went over the top,
stop for a moment,
and then slid right down again,
which caused women in the theaters that saw that to faint because they did know
that this was simply nonsense,
that it was fiction.
And I think that the critical point to bear in mind therefore,
is that as a filmic war,
the war turned into myth at the very moment that it was being fought.
Nobody had ever seen the landscape of the dark side of the moon that was created
by industrialized war between 1914 to 1918 and the way it was represented by
film was completely fictional because film comes straight out of theater.
It has a proceed IOM arch and has a vanishing point than anyone who's ever been
anywhere near a battle.
We'll realize that battles don't have vanishing points.
People vanish in them,
but they go in every conceivable direction.
The of war became a matter of myth right in the middle of the war itself and it
became a battle of myth to be remembered.
I'll give you another example which makes the point really powerful,
very,
very powerful.
In February,
1916 the German army decided to push through German French lines at Van don.
This big 10 months battle,
which is the biggest of all time took place and in the course of it,
a series of completely made up stories turned into legend.
One is called the trench of the bayonets,
and what it shows is there were no trenches in the battle of it.
Then the word isolated pockets of men and big underground forts.
And there was simply artillery barrage going on day and night for 10 months.
So little pockets of men would be caught in one part of the battle and they
stayed put to make sure that the Germans would not get through.
The French line was in a passer on par.
They won't get through and they didn't.
One group of such men were almost certainly buried by a landslide because the
weight of artillery barrage in the mud would mean that earth would move when
indeed the,
uh,
the artillery barrage hit a particularly wet part of the,
of the front.
So a group of men were buried alive,
which is a very normal practice in the course of the first world war,
the German group of soldiers,
the platoon that took it put bayonets basically sticking up out of the ground to
indicate to the French where to find the dead so that they could be buried
during,
uh,
allowing the fighting.
The French didn't interpret it that way.
What they said was,
here are 15 French men who stood with their band.
That's there until they were buried alive and they didn't move an inch in the
past on par.
Now,
this is a completely made up story,
but it became a sacred site commemorated every 2020 2nd of February,
1917 1819 in,
in other words,
the war itself created a mythic set of representations of war that have come out
to the present.
The Great War created myth in other ways.
Another one came from the landing and globally now glibly was a Turkish
peninsula south of Istanbul,
Constantinople.
Then it's about a four hour taxi drive and lousy traffic probably took longer
than,
but the idea of the allies was to knock Turkey out of the war,
help Russia and possibly in circle Germany by not attacking directly through the
western front,
but coming around through Asia Minor.
This landing was a catastrophic failure.
It was the brainchild of Winston Churchill who until 1940 when Hitler made him
the great man that we all remember,
it was a complete failure politically in a military affairs glibly was his idea,
and he's,
he's,
he shared in the form of what is now called orientalism.
A complete underestimation of the capacity of a Muslim populations,
populations,
Brown people to fight against Europeans.
So nobody had a look at the ground where the allies were supposed to land at
glibly.
They didn't actually take account of the fact that the were very big cliffs to
climb and when they got there,
they just reproduce trench warfare that had already existed.
It was a complete failure.
The landing though took place on the 24th 25th the night of the 24th fifth 25th
of April,
1915 and the people used for it.
We're Australian and New Zealand troops alongside British and French ones.
That landing was the birth of the Australian nation and to this day,
Anzac Day,
Australia,
New Zealand,
expeditionary core,
Anzac Day,
our is sacred.
It's the,
it's the 4th of July and Australia.
It's the moment of celebration through the shedding of blood,
the winning of national pride.
Now this is the point I'm trying to make initially is that remembering the first
World War is remembering sacred themes that define nations and the oddity of the
first world war is that these nations were defined.
First of all because they're a part of imperial powers.
But this war was at the one one in the same time,
the apogee and the beginning of the end of empire.
And hence nations that affirmed their loyalty to Britain by dying on the beaches
of Galit.
Billy,
you're in the hills of glibly earned the right to break,
break away from Britain.
And this sacred moment is how the Great War turned into myth.
If you think this is light,
you're mistaken.
This is big time politics to this day.
Yesterday in the Sydney Morning Morning Herald,
two Australian politicians virtually came to blows about how to remember
deliberately because it is at the core of the notion or the idea of what the
nation has to be.
So the first point I want to make as remembering the first World War is
remembering a series of myths and are iconic in the sense that they describe not
just what happened at a particular moment,
but the describe what the rest of the 20th century might become and did become.
And that is the second point I think I'd like to draw to your attention.
What makes remembering the first world war so important is that it became the
way in which war was configured throughout the 20th century in Europe.
In many respects,
this is a defining difference between the United States and Europe.
The Second World War in this,
in this country is quite different from the first.
The United States didn't really suffer the injuries of any major European
country.
In the first World War,
100,000 American soldiers died in the first world war,
perhaps 40,000 of them.
There's a dispute on this,
but perhaps 40,000 of them died from the Spanish flu,
the worst influence epidemic in history that had everybody.
It's civilians,
it's soldiers,
but it particularly prayed as per many mutant viruses do on young adults.
So it got soldiers,
well,
100,000 dead was roughly just roughly what the British army suffered in three
weeks on the battle of the Somme.
In one battle,
the scale of casualties in the first world war is what makes it everybody's
business.
And the second reason why remembering the first world war is iconic is that it
is universal in Europe.
It's family history.
Let me give you an example of what that means.
If you ever visit the extraordinary power of individual,
uh,
graveyards at the scene of the landings in Normandy,
you will find that there are graves of 3000 American soldiers who died in the
course of the first day of the landing on the 6th of June,
1944 now that landing on the 6th of June,
1944 was terrible.
It was an extraordinary day.
It was a day that should be remembered and is remembered.
If any of you see the Steven Spielberg play saving a film,
Saving Private Ryan,
you'll see it.
It is iconic.
It should be the first day of the battle of the Somme.
On the 1st of July,
1916 was 20,000 British men killed.
The first day of the landing at Normandy.
3000 Americans killed that and landing at Normandy compared to the battle of the
Somme shows us that the iconic battle for Britain of the first row was six times
as murderous in one day as the landings in Normandy.
And that sheer scale of casualties means that remembering the great war remains
remembering loss of life that became universal throughout families throughout
Europe.
Now this,
this is extraordinary in many respects,
until 1914,
war was not democratic.
Military service was not democratic either.
It was aristocratic and rural in terms of the officer corps.
That's why the cavalry mattered so much.
They came from the land or it was more or less the men whom general,
um,
and the general who defeated Napoleon Wellington put it,
who were the scum of the earth,
either the unemployable,
overpopulation of major cities or indeed the over the unemployable populations
of,
uh,
of rural life in Europe as well.
Now,
what happens in 1914 is conscription,
universal conscription and to dating the war presented armies of a size that had
never before been a been pulled together and these armies suffered casualties of
roughly one out of eight killed.
And one out of three wounded.
We're talking about 70 million men in uniform in the first world war.
9 million men killed roughly 25 million man wounded one out of every two men who
served in the first world.
What was a casualty?
There were 8 million prisoners of war.
And in those camps,
illness was likely to kill you more than anything else.
And critical thing to bear in mind therefore is that the first world war created
an astonishing and unprecedented the challenge of commemoration.
And the first challenge was the missing.
And I want to take you through the commemorative forms that the first world war
created,
which created cultural practices that are still very important today.
Anybody going to England today,
and I mean today was their last weekend in Oxford.
We'll see everybody wearing a little red poppy in your lapel.
And this is what you buy for a couple of pennies,
whatever you want to give as a contribution to a charity called the Royal
British Legion,
the biggest charity in Britain.
And it's still to this day,
the biggest charity for those families and indeed survivors,
um,
and successive generations of those who serve their country and who were wounded
or died in it.
Now,
the critical thing to bear in mind about this is that the mythic representation
of war,
which came out of film
has been matched by what I would call a family representation of war.
That comes through cultural practices of remembrance.
We should never ever get away from the fact that remembering is a business that
people make money out of it.
That's why films sell so well.
The history channel is dominated by stories about war.
It's an important thing to bear in mind that people make money out of
representing war.
It's an important thing to keep in mind,
but that's too cynical to suffice for a discussion of how uh,
the first world war was remembered.
It was remembered and still is remembered within families.
And the answer why is that?
It's because of the universalization of bereavement.
Now,
what's the problem?
The PR problems are threefold.
The first is the missing.
The second is in some sense the irrelevance of conventional religious practices.
And the third is the search for some kind of collective statement of why these
men died.
For what,
what price victory.
The missing half of those men who died in the first world war and we're talking
about 9 million men have known on graves,
not a trace of them exists.
This,
by the way,
is exactly the same proportion of those who were killed at Ground Zero on nine
11 half of them have vanished completely.
There are traces that matter the great deal to the families of the survivors,
the survivors who need something to remember to mourn.
The fact that roughly 4 million men died without a trace made commemorating more
very,
very difficult because conventional religious practices require a site,
a grave,
a place to go to where individuals can honor those who die and
take their lives up.
Once again,
let the loss go.
What possible ways did they have to handle this during the war?
Nothing because the confusion over casualties of war,
which always happens in war time was overwhelming.
If a family got a message saying your husband,
your brother,
your son,
your fiance is missing in action,
it could mean anything.
It could mean that the individual was in a prison camp on the other side of the
line.
It could mean that the individual was in a hospital.
It could mean that there was a confusion of identity and that the person was
still alive,
but,
uh,
somebody else found his dog tag.
It could mean that the person had been blown to pieces and there was nothing
that remained of him.
None of that could be sorted out until the end of the war.
And even then,
it couldn't be sorted out.
The loss of knowledge,
the lack of knowledge about the most fundamental question of war is the most
poignant origin of a series of commemorative practices and followed it.
Now,
given the scale of the losses,
the conventional churches were not able to handle the problem of helping the
bereaved or those who were as it were in no man's land in purgatory.
In fact,
purgatory is an interesting idea.
If you think about it,
it's center to a certain kind of popular Catholicism in the 19th century.
Purgatory means that people who are,
um,
on the way to heaven have to wait awhile and maybe,
maybe just the good works that you and I might do will help them get there
sooner rather than later.
It's a medieval idea.
The Catholic Church had to jettison the idea of purgatory,
which died in the first world war because no one wanted to put up with the idea
that an individual who died for his country had a wait for a hundred years in
purgatory in order to be able to get to heaven.
Religious practices had to change to handle the unprecedented losses of war.
Those who went to the churches for solace found very little because it was very
little.
The churchmen could do,
could say,
why did I lose three sons?
What did they die for?
The phrases,
the knowable phrases of patriotism last only so long and most of the time don't
get you through the night.
Well,
what individuals do,
the first thing they did was to move to the pagan perimeters of Christianity.
John Merriman referred you to a wonderful film by Ebell Goss about the return of
the dead called Jacuzzi.
Accused,
which is accusing war,
accusing the sign of not stopping wars accusing everybody of this insanity,
uh,
had no end to it.
Well,
the pagan perimeters of Christianity is the area are the areas where the,
the,
um,
the account lives.
It's the areas where people believe photo Mya,
they have no choice in extra sensory perception.
Now,
this is a period not just of the film industry,
but the emergence of radio.
It's a,
uh,
a world where,
telegraphy was the quite normal means of communication with their underground
cables,
Reuters dispatched stories all over the world.
So for millions of families,
the idea of getting in touch with the missing or the dad is seemed quite
appealing.
And these are not fools.
These are not people who are,
as it were,
bought by the Elmer Gantries of this world.
These are ordinary people or very intelligent people who are prepared to suspend
disbelief about extra sensory perception in order to be able to find some
solace,
some way of understanding the world in which they lived.
It wasn't extraordinary.
Efflorescence development of spiritualism,
of seances.
One of the great carriers of this message was Arthur Conan Doyle,
who was the author of the great,
the ultimate rationalist Sherlock Holmes.
But when his son died and was missing,
completely missing,
he became one of the great figures in the development of the spiritualist
movement.
Churches have no part in that because speaking to the dad has no mediation.
Christianity couldn't be interested in this.
Jewish religion has not,
no time for it.
Islam has no time for it whatsoever,
but it just shows you that the scale of the catastrophe of human loss and the
first world war challenged conventional institutions and frameworks for
understanding what was happening.
Well,
if,
if sounds are a kind of collective remembrance they created as it were,
the precedent for the ones that have laughed their most powerful marks,
not only on Europe but beyond it as well,
and these are war memorials.
The need to create a,
I said we're a substitute tomb,
a substitute place in which in front of which to mourn is what creates the
extraordinary vogue of war memorials.
And you don't have to go very far to see them or you have to do is go through
Commons and you'll see two or memorials that were created at the same moment
right after the first world war.
When you see the names of civil war,
that's who were Yale man.
When you go through Commons on the walls,
you should recognize that that was completed in the 1920s at the same time as
there is a facade,
a war memorial in front of Commons with the names of the battles that American
soldiers fought in.
In front of that is a cenotaph and the cenotaph,
an empty tomb says that these men died for liberty and so on,
but it is an empty tomb.
This is the critical point to bear in mind.
The enormous development of commemorative forms in particular sculpture,
architectural war memorials in the 20th century comes from the first world war.
Anyone who goes,
and I think it's marvelous that we can talk about this in this particular room.
Anyone who goes to see Maya Lin's Vietnam Veterans Memorial,
we'll see an outcome of a lecture on First World War commemoration that took
place in this room where Maya Lin was a student.
She studied first world war memorials.
Okay.
In order to create the Vietnam Veterans Memorial.
Why?
If you go to the Vietnam Veterans Memorial,
you'll understand the genius,
the first World War commemoration,
the only thing that matters,
author names,
the names are what matters and the highly polished granite surface in the
Vietnam veterans memorial has your own reflection forced back upon you to touch
the names,
is the way to find a means inadequate,
perhaps symbolic perhaps to bring the dead back home,
to bring them to the center of American history in the middle of the mall at the
intersection between the Lincoln memorial and the Washington Memorial.
It is an extraordinary gathering together of the bones of the remains of the
dead who were buried in Europe or never found.
Now,
why does this matter?
It matters because the universalization of mourning,
a bereavement in the first world war meant that these war memorials are all over
Europe.
They're everywhere.
There are 38,000 of them in England.
Every village has one.
Every commune,
I think bar 12 in all of France,
there 30,000 of them in France alone.
And these war memorials are extraordinary in many respects,
and I want to tell you about them today.
There are places where next Tuesday on the 11th of November,
there will be ceremonies in France,
the mayor of the town,
it's a holiday,
it's a public holiday in France.
The mayor of the town will be at the head of a procession and in this,
by the way,
is choreographed all over the country in which there will be,
oh a hundred school children who will march in the rain and the sleet.
It doesn't matter to the local war memorial.
And what happens then is that the mayor reads out the names of those from a
small village or from a town who died in the first world war and the children in
the school after the name of Cohen.
All Dow will say,
praise song.
We'll answer for the man who aren't there.
This bonding between the living and the dead,
the bringing back of the bed to their own villages,
to their homes was a substitute burial ceremony for the ones that could never
take place.
Now,
how did it all happen?
The first point that has to be made is that the commemorative wave took place
through political leadership and politics means many things.
The first thing it has to mean is that there is a fundamental difference between
the way in which men are remembered in the winners and the losers.
In the case of Germany where they were 2 million soldiers who died in the first
world war,
this is an enormously difficult problem.
The reason is that you not only need to remember the dead,
but you have to find a way and a form to answer on an eternal question.
The question is,
how is it possible to glorify those who die in war without glorifying war
itself?
The extraordinary wave of commemorative activity,
the cultural practices of commemoration that were universal in Europe in the
1920s and 1930s have many different answers to it,
but most of the time what happens is that politics became local.
That small groups of people in small towns and villages took it upon themselves.
Yeah.
To answer the question,
what will we do?
How will we remember the men of our village
and given the numbers we're talking about three,
four brothers in agrarian towns,
we're talking about fathers and sons who never came back.
We're talking about the absolutely personal face to face,
culture of village life.
Everyone knew the names,
everybody knew the families.
Uh,
what this means is that it may be the case that high politics set out certain
lines,
the cabinets,
the politicians,
the generals.
But what's extraordinary about Europe between the wars is how democratic
commemoration was and how much life,
there wasn't civil society in order to create forms that were separate.
That's why I mentioned the Poppy Fund.
This is a private organization.
It's not a public charity.
It's not the state.
It's civil society is speaking.
It's compassionate language of remembering not only the fallen but those left
behind the widows,
the orphans and so on.
Now I'll give you an example of how civil society and state power differ and
vary.
On the 14th of July,
1919 just two weeks after the signing of the peace treaty on the 28th of June,
1919 when the Germans were forced to accept the terms of the treaty of
Versailles,
there was a victory parade in Paris and that victory parade had a march pastor.
The Sean's the Lycee through the Arc de Triomphe.
It's only happened twice in history and this was one of them to celebrate the
victory.
French were there,
the Americans were there,
the Brits were there,
the Italians were there.
All the allies were there.
Now the two things that happened,
one was that George claim,
also the French prime minister decided in this spectacle we need as a worse
symbol of the lost generation.
So he had a paper,
Mashiach Cata,
Ofac built very big,
ornate plinth.
And on top of it was a Santa Taf,
an empty tomb to symbolize the tombs of all those soldiers who died in the war,
half of whom have no known graves.
And to start the victory parade Claremont's so insisted that the people who lead
the way are the most badly mutilated men of the war.
The Google car say the men with broken faces,
the man without arms,
the men without legs,
and the use of this vanguard of the suffering transformed a victory parade into
a day of mourning.
This was extraordinary.
It was absent extraordinary.
The Brits decided if there's going to be something on the 14th of July,
we better do something to,
and it'll take five days for us to get everybody back over the 19th of July,
we need,
we need a victory parade too,
because three quarters of a million British men died in the war,
another 250,000 from the empire and so on.
Dominion's a million man for the British forces died in the first role.
We need a victory parade.
So they asked the architect,
Edmund luncheons to put together another paper,
Pinochet Memorial call the Cenotaph,
an empty tomb.
And they put it right in the middle of Whitehall official London,
right next to 10 Downing Street next to Buckingham Palace.
You know,
basically a,
a small stroll down to the houses of parliament right in the middle of official
London.
And they had their parade,
but that wasn't the end of it.
2 million people came to it and they all deposited whatever they had to offer to
the debt of the Great War because this was an empty tomb.
Now it wasn't the empty tomb of Christ,
it was a Greek form.
And this drove the churchmen leading the Church of England apoplectic because it
meant that the language of commemoration was ecumenical and not Christian.
And why should that be?
Lachance was the man who designed New Delhi.
He was the architect of empire,
and he wanted a memorial that would suffice for Hindu soldiers who had died,
Muslim soldiers,
Jewish soldiers,
Anglican,
Catholic,
IRS,
whatever,
or people have no belief at all.
And he found it.
He found the simplest possible way.
And as a result of this extraordinary outpouring of feeling literally flowers.
They kept on having to shovel them away because there was so many things left.
Understandably.
These are families who finally found a way to express perhaps a form of symbolic
exchange.
It happens in the Vietnam Wall.
Two people leave things.
Why these people whose names are on the wall,
those people who died represented by the Cenotaph have given everything I need
to give something pilgrimages hard.
It's not tourism.
It should be difficult and you should.
You should give,
not just get.
Now,
the critical thing there is that clearly the British people voted with their
feet for the national war memorial.
So the cabinet says things,
could you do it again this time in stone?
And he did.
He did it again and stone and a year later when the unknown soldier was buried
in Westminster Abbey,
where did people go?
They went and paid their respects.
You can still do it today.
The IB is the home of kings and poets.
Now the people's monument is the Cenotaph in London,
in Whitehall,
not the Church of the kings,
but it's the sacred space of the people and it remains.
So to this day.
Now that man Edwin luncheons designed another set of war memorials that lead us
directly to Myelin.
Tepe fall,
t,
h I e p via email as a small village that no longer exists in the psalm in
northern France.
And there he was asked 18 years later to do a memorial for the 73,000 British
soldiers who died in that one battle and have known own graves.
And what he created was an extraordinary arch,
an arch of triumph that basically has small arches on top of it.
And then nothing,
he reduced the arch of triumph to nothingness.
And the only thing you do is when you walk up to it.
My eyesight is dreadful,
but younger people do it too.
It just depends.
When you get close.
For me,
it's very close for other people,
it's further away.
You all of a sudden see that the walls are this arch that he built and teeth vol
are completely covered with names.
There's a vanishing point.
We suddenly see them from a distance.
You can't see,
it just looks like a facade.
They heard the names and it's that which Myelin heard about in this lecture hall
when Vincent Scully talked about luncheons and commemoration that inspired her
to create the Vietnam Veterans Memorial.
She's told me what it felt like to sit in this room and do it.
She actually submitted her,
designed for that memorial,
uh,
as the design that was ultimately,
the,
the winning design in the competition that was anonymous by the way.
She got a B plus for it in her class.
I'll leave that aside.
Judgment is mine,
Sayeth the Lord.
All I can,
all I can do,
all I can do is to tell you that the forms that were created in the cenotaph
were ones that have endured throughout the 20th century to describe how war is
remembered.
And now the cenotaph,
as I say,
is Pre-christian.
It's one more move away from the institutionalization of religion.
And it's not that the sacred died in 20th century Europe.
It moved out of the churches.
It can be found elsewhere.
And one of the places where it will be found next Tuesday is in front of war
memorials that were placed all over villages,
towns,
marketplaces,
all over Europe.
So let me return to that process.
The first I said is political,
small groups of people,
the busy bodies,
the committee man that always exist in small towns with nothing better to do
retired men or men of leisure or sometimes women.
And what they did was they wanted to know,
we want to design,
design this ourselves.
Well the first thing you have to figure out is how much does it cost?
And hence we should always recognize the commemoration is a business and the
cost factor actually matters substantially.
The reason why it matters substantially is that if you want something
sculptural,
if you want something like a piece of architecture,
the cheapest possible form of stone is an obelisk.
You know,
you don't have to do much and just hack it here,
there and that's it.
And it has a great advantage,
which is that it's Egyptian has pre-christian.
Again,
it doesn't require you to distinguish between Protestant Catholics,
Jews,
or anybody else.
It's an ecumenical form and it's the most popular one.
The second problem is that in France in particular,
Germany has its own headaches,
but in France in particular,
church and state had been separated in 19 five and rather violently separated,
no crosses,
except in some Catholic areas where they said,
I don't really care.
We're going to have a cross no matter what.
Which is true in Catholic Brittany in the northwest of the country,
but most of the time they're not crosses.
What they show primarily are two kinds of representations.
The first is of a gallic rooster,
which again could be bought through a mail order catalog or a soldier.
The poor Lou,
the French,
the British like to see their soldiers shaved for the,
for the French.
The idea of a soldier should be somebody who was a hairy one while lose somebody
who never shaved.
So having a bar,
a beard is being masculine,
being a tough guy,
being a soldier who won the war.
So upwa Lou could be bought again on a made a mail order catalog.
But overwhelmingly,
and this is a very important point,
overwhelmingly the images are not triumphal.
There are more painful and again these,
these were decided by small groups of people who put together money in order to
describe the ways in which war memorials should be organized,
should be designed,
and indeed should be paid for,
and they were paid for by popular subscription overwhelmingly panties,
Su Frank's deutschmarks,
whatever,
whatever you had.
That's the way it was done.
Now what about the inscriptions?
Once more,
I want to reinforce the point that I made earlier about the democratic nature of
loss.
95% of war memorials list people either alphabetically or by the year or the
time in which they died,
the sequence of their death.
Only 5% of all war memorials in Europe that I've ever seen and I've tried to
collect material all over the place on this have men listed by rank.
There is a democracy of death and of commemoration in highly any Galitary in
societies.
There was something extraordinary that goes on when,
when loss is so general,
it becomes apparent that it isn't possible to separate those who died in uniform
from those who,
uh,
who in a high rank or from those who died,
as private soldiers.
Now,
one important point to bear in mind is that once the choice of place was made
and the choice of form was made and the money was preserved,
uh,
was,
gathered together and paid to the artist or the sculpture sculptor who would,
who would do this,
then we come to the,
as it were,
the,
uh,
the third part of the commemorative process.
The first is political,
and by that I mean small politics more than big politics.
The second is business,
the money,
the commissioning,
uh,
the putting together of the project.
But the third is the ritual.
What do people do when they stand in front of a war memorial?
And the answer is very different things.
The first thing that happens in the front of war memorials and it still happens,
is that women enter the narrative of war.
Women are at the center of the commemorative practice.
They are not at the center of the narratives of war from the battlefield or
indeed from the military perspective itself.
There are those who believe that that indeed,
the gendering of the narratives of war,
uh,
separates the stories told by soldiers and novels and,
and uh,
and memoirs,
uh,
from those of the societies in which they,
for which they fought and,
and for which they died.
I'm not sure if that is true or not,
but what we can say,
and there are thousands of photographs that show it,
is that the ritual that happens in front of memorials are rituals of families.
And in conventional terms,
by that I mean historically over determined ways.
Women have been associated with morning practices since the Egyptians.
There are tombs in the,
in the queen,
the valley of the Queens and lox,
Luxor that's show professional mourners,
women who have tears painted on there on the cheeks,
uh,
from the,
from the time of the pharaohs.
Whether that is true or not.
The notion of Mater Dolorosa,
you know Stabat Mater,
his mother was,
there is a Catholic trope of great power and importance in understanding how
societies can figure loss of life and more so the first point is that women and
children families are there.
The second is there is a didactic function.
School children come there and this I think is a very important point to bear in
mind.
Overwhelmingly this is true in Germany until the 1930s Italy.
It's true until late 1920s and it's true all over Britain and France and
certainly in the dominions.
The rituals have a byword that dominate the message.
It is never again the phrase we frequently associate with the Holocaust with war
against genocide.
Yes,
that's true,
but the phrase never again comes out of the first world war and it's what
dominates the commemorative practices of the interwar period.
This is the war to end all wars.
This is the war that makes war unimpossible.
This is a war so dreadful that it is not at all the purpose of those who go to
commemorative forms to prepare the next generation for their turn.
On the contrary,
the notion of commemoration and into war Europe is never again,
and that explains I think why the commemorative power of the period around the
first world war is not repeated after the second in France.
You can see this anywhere in Britain.
It's there too.
In Germany,
they're more and more difficult reasons obviously to handle this,
and in eastern Europe where the massacres was so gigantic,
it's almost a possible,
but what happens in western Europe is that the names of those who die in the
second world war,
a tacked onto first world war memorials.
Part of the reason is financial.
If the first world war impoverished Europe,
the Second World War bankrupted it and without the Marshall Plan,
who knows?
The important point is though that there's another reason.
How many times can you say never again if the idea was that these men died to
make war impossible.
In other words,
their sacrifices with such as to eliminate the need for their children to go
water again.
Then what do you do in 1939 and this is true by the way,
in Germany to where night to the 1st of September,
1939,
the outbreak of the Second World War was not graded by marching bands and
[inaudible] and parades and so on.
It was a day of sadness in Germany as it was elsewhere because everybody knew
and they knew because the great war had told them what war is.
The conclusion I want to,
uh,
to draw on is this remembering the first world war has taken many different
forms.
I've dealt with a filmmaker mystification of it.
There's a big business in novels and memoirs in an area of what we might call
factoids that are half fictional and half true.
Robert Graves,
goodbye to all that is still in prince 80 years after he wrote it.
There are many such novels all quiet on the western front that are,
there were enormous bestsellers.
We should accept the fact that the media matters.
But I think the critical point to bear in mind is that the casualties of the of
the first world war was so devastating that even the losses of the Second World
War didn't change.
The landscape of remembrance that was constructed between 1918 and 1939 war
means something in Europe that it doesn't mean in this country and the reasons
can be found in all of these commemorative practices.
It is clear to me that political culture follows history,
follows the understandings people develop of the world in which they live.
European see war differently from Americans and it doesn't stop there from being
militaristic groups and those like the Nazis who wanted to get it right this
time around and reverse the verdict of 1918 and under the treaty of Versailles.
But there's no,
no doubt in my mind that the first world war message of never again survived the
Nazis survived Stalin to create a different kind of Europe in which armies don't
matter anymore.
They're there.
But in the question of a great historian,
James Sheehan from Stanford who just wrote a history of 20th century in the
question that he put in his title,
we have,
I think the final legacy of the commemoration of the first World War.
His book is entitled where have all the soldiers gone
in late 20th century Europe.
States are defined in terms of the way in which they defend the wellbeing of
their populations.
No longer a states defined in terms of the military force that they can deploy
in defense of their national interests or their imperial power.
The first world war put,
as it were,
the beginnings hammered in the nails in the coffin of the old vision that the
state is that institution which has the monopoly on the legitimate use of
physical force.
The story of warfare killed the old idea of state sovereignty.
It wasn't dead before the Nazis made it necessary for us to develop something
different.
But it is the remembrance of the first World War which left traces in families,
which are the most powerful reasons why the first world war has become and
remains the iconic disaster that has created a Europe that no one had ever seen
before.
And that was vastly different than the minds of ordinary people than the Europe
that existed in 1914 thank you very much.